it's almost like i don't remember
who i was before i became anna masreya
because she cured and
healed so many
things that i have been through
that i have experienced so she's
definitely here to stay
[Music]
when i'm doing my makeup i put some
incense
for a nice smell and good vibes
means i'm an egyptian woman in arabic
i'm gonna give like elegant naked today
it's very earthy colors
everything is gonna be like brown and
like
matte and i'm almost gonna give like a
nude illusion
i'm not gonna wear my pads or any like
boobs i'm going with like my natural
body
i'm gonna give leg before i started
doing drag i was like reluctant to move
my body in like certain
ways i was always very aware of like my
mannerisms and like
if i was being too feminine or if i was
looking
too gay or stuff like that but ever
since i did drag
i have a completely different
relationship with myself
and um with the way i allow myself to
move
i i speak for myself but i also feel
it's a very
communal struggle that is understood by
queer arabs and muslims
everywhere from egypt and beyond okay
i grew up very in the closet
i didn't even want to admit to myself
that i was gay
you know in egypt there are very defined
roles of what it means to be a man and
what it means to be a woman and i
felt like i had to
prove my masculinity to the people who
doubted it
i was captain of the wrestling team i
was
always so angry they don't tell you that
you can be a boy and you can play with
barbies
or that you can be a boy and that you
can put on makeup they don't
they don't let you think that that's
okay keep in mind i'm not just
a gay person or a queer person i'm an
artist you know what i mean and
drag is my art and i always from when i
was very young i think
i had a lot of trouble with myself
because when i closed my
eyes or when i was alone you know in the
shower
or like in the bathroom there was this
woman in the mirror and she would
perform i was her she was me
but just like an alter ego and i didn't
understand that
so first and foremost i had to
understand that
i had to understand what that meant
and it's okay because your eyebrows are
what
sisters not twins
these might be cousins actually but
we'll see
we have sold a lot of tickets we're
definitely gonna be a full house
queer arab culture you don't have very
much of it like this
show and all my shows in the very
beginning it started
off as like you know queer arabs were
coming and then it expanded beyond that
and now there's like
straight arab men who are coming to this
drag show
i tie the arabness and the queerness
and so now they're exposed to like a
scene that before they
didn't know about or didn't have like
any reference to
again i just wish my face was already on
so i can go party but i'm nowhere
i need to probably start like speeding
up a little bit junior year of
college i found out about a show
called rupaul's drag race and i
literally looked at it like this
these are mostly men who are
dressing up as women
lip singing putting on makeup
feeling fabulous wearing heels
this is what i see inside
and i had never seen anything in the
media
or anything on tv that was like that
how come they can do it and i can't
queer
arabs and queer egyptians are
here to we are real
tangible complex human beings
with many different aspects to our
identities and our who we are as people
all of this was just a foundation now
i'm gonna start painting my face
are you ready all right two big
defining factors for me from
2020 were the black lives matter
movement
and the death of
queer egyptian activist sarah hagezi
and how me being a queer north african
how do i speak
up for my african-american or my african
brothers and sisters how do i
as a queer arabs speak up for people
like sarah higgesi
when i a lot of the times feel the same
fears
and the same anxieties that
she faced in her lifetime
it's so difficult to exist as a pure
arab person
in the arab world even here it's
difficult
i had a very unique situation where
i came out in the new york times
on a very public scale
before that you know i had started
telling my friends my
very secretly and like only people that
i trusted that i was
gay and you know i'm living in new york
city now and i'm doing this drag show
the amount of positivity and the
positive
response that i received as a queer
person
everyone who i love has supported me
has backed me up has elevated me to like
new levels of success and
i really think that it has to do with
the fact that i
showcased a bravery that
terrified me for so long that when i
did that it's like oh she did that
like it's crazy i'm like so tired and we
still are gonna switch personalities
completely you know
to tell her to tell them where the merch
and the raffle tickets are
okay i'll tell them okay alrighty bye
my friends are amazing my friends have
been the ones who
make all this happen really i started
going to many more drag shows
in real life and seeing drag queens and
being like this is so
cool but i don't feel like it completes
me
i want to see a performance by haifawabi
i want to see a performance by nancy
azram i want to see a performance by
elisa i want to
see the air of women
with the big curly hair and the eyebrows
and the
polished and the i need to see the women
that i saw on tv growing up i need to
see
so now i'm getting the queer
aspect of things i'm exposed to those
but it's still missing the arab-ness
that's a huge
part of my identity if i can't see it
it i i need to make it exist here and
that's sort of where
everything started to come together
i'm so proud to be an egyptian muslim
ana masrea puts together all the
the struggles that i face as a queer
person living in egypt
and the beauty of everything that i love
about
egypt and egyptian culture and egyptian
women
an egyptian taunt and she puts them all
together
seeing anna masreya in the mirror
i felt like i was seeing a drag
that speaks to me
that i was giving myself permission
to do all the things that society taught
me
i couldn't do and i
felt free and empowered
and [ __ ] beautiful
i did not used to look like this baby
yeah just practice i used to do it a lot
more
in the beginning when i was first
starting drugs like it was still like
fun and i was like oh my god i want to
paint my face
and i used to come home from work every
single day and just like paint my face
and it was so fun and that's how i
learned how to do it
but now it's like now it's different
because it takes a lot of time
and i need to look perfect back then i
didn't care about looking perfect
[Music]
i made a mess on you like it
isn't she pretty and then i added all
these
feathers and they're gonna fly with this
fan
and i'm gonna put it on before the tape
comes out
coming out
i hope she's not destroyed after tonight
if i got her back home in one piece
then that's great if not i'll buy
another one
i want to bend the ideas of
gender that i was taught to believe
were so rigid i want to bend them
i want to break them and i want to show
that i
can express that
woman that i saw inside of me without
anything
being so binary and clipped and locked
in
can i see can i see
i think i'm falling in love and then the
fan
and the feathers you see it
everything about my show i wanted to
feel like i
am doing this in the middle of the
pyramids
you know what i mean like that it's
authentically egyptian
it's produced by egyptians it's worked
on by egyptians
i miss my
home and my country so much
that everything that i do is like and
love owed to it
like i can't believe that i left you
but i left you so that i could be free
and now i'm i'm
doing everything that i'm doing to prove
my love for it and to prove how much
the country and the culture means to me
and how
beautiful i find it it comes from such
an innocent place
all the songs that i perform in drag are
the songs that
my mom would be playing in the car while
we're driving from heliopolis to my idea
or while we're driving from magic to
zombies
i'm sitting next to her and it's all it
was always the
the female artist i i used to question
why
why don't i resonate with these men
artists like i resonate with these women
don't get me wrong i love the hashem
vessels and the um's of the world i do
i really do but i always resonated
more with the females and drag has
allowed me
to not question to just
be to just allow
khalas this is the way it is this
is the way i am
i'm not bound by society's
definition of what i have to do
last time my most recent show there was
a friend of mine
she stood up on stage
she held the microphone in her hand
and she said i am gay i am muslim
and i am egyptian and i am no longer
scared
there are no words to express the beauty
of
hearing something like that because i
know the pain and the struggle of what
it takes to say that
and the fact that i've created a space
where people can feel free to be
themselves
and to own their truths
it's so overwhelmingly beautiful
and i want people around the world to
experience
that same beauty that we have curated
here in new york
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone
on a very quick note so i can start
holding my waist like this
i just jumped off the stage and my core
set ripped
but it's okay at least i can breathe
guys huh are 10 000 rhinestones
on my body
[Applause]
[Music]
saved my life in so many different ways
i know that there are some of you out
there
who may be curious or who may
feel like they want to try drag
but you here in my space
are alive whoever the [ __ ] you
wanna be
[Applause]
and i chose this i chose the light i
chose
to finally break free
and just be myself because
enough was enough so
is ana masrea gonna be around
for five years yes she gonna be around
for 20 years yes she gonna be around for
50 years
absolutely and anna masreya allowed me
to let it all go
[Music]
you